- [Voiceover] So where we left off,
I had this two-dimensional vector field V,
and I have it pictured here as
kind of a yellow vector field
and I just stuck it in three dimensions
in kind of an awkward way
where I put it on the XY plane
and said pretend this
is in three dimensions.
And then when you describe the rotation,
around each point what we
were familiar with is 2D curl,
that's where you get this
vector field, it's not quite
a 3D vector field because
you're only assigning
points on the XY plane to
three dimensional vectors,
rather than every point
in space to a vector,
but we're getting there.
So here let's actually
extend this to a fully
three dimensional vector field,
and first of all let me just kind of
clear up the board from the computations
we did in the last part.
And as I do that kind
of start thinking about
how you might want to
extend the vector field
that I have here that's
pretty much two dimensional
into three dimensions.
And one idea you might, we'll
kind of get rid of the circles
and the plane, is to
take this vector field
and then just kind of copy
it to different slices.
So, you might get something
kind of like this.
And then, I've drawn each
slice a little bit sparser
than the original one, so
technically that original
one if you look on the XY plane
I've pictured many more vectors,
but it's really the same vector field,
and all I've done here is
said at every slice in space,
just copy that same vector field.
So if you look from above,
you can maybe see how really
it's just the same vector
field kind of copied a bunch,
and if you look at it each
slice, you know in the same way
that in the XY plane,
you've got this vector field
sitting on the slice,
every other part of space
will have that.
And even though there's only
what, like six or seven slices
displayed here, in principal
you're thinking that
every one of those infinitely
many slices of space
has a copy of this vector field.
And in a formula, what does that mean?
Well what it means is
what it means is that
we're taking not just X
and Y as input points,
But we're gonna start taking Z in as well.
So if I go, I'm gonna say that
Z is an input point as well.
And I want to be considering these
as vectors in three dimensions,
so rather than just saying
that that it's got X and Y
components, I'm gonna pretend
like it has a Z component
that just happens to
be zero for this case.
And the fact that you
have a Z in the input,
but the output doesn't depend on the Z,
corresponds to the fact that
all the slices are the same,
as you change the Z direction
the vectors won't change at all,
they're just carbon copies of each other.
And the fact this output
has a Z component,
but it just happens to be
zero is what corresponds
to the fact that it's very flat looking,
you know, none of them point
up or down in the Z direction,
they're all purely X and Y.
So, as three dimensional vector fields go,
this one is only barely a
three dimensional vector field,
it's kind of phoning it in
as far as three dimensional
vector fields are concerned,
but it'll be quite good
for our example here,
because now if we start
thinking of this as representing
a three dimensional fluid
flow, so now rather than
just kind of the fluid
flow like the one I have
pictured over here, where
you've got water molecules
moving in two dimensions
and it's very easy to
understand clockwise rotation,
counter clockwise rotation,
things like that, whereas
over here it's a very
kind of chaotic three
dimensional fluid flow,
but because it's so flat
if you view it from above
it's still loosely the same just kind of
counter clockwise over here on the right,
and clockwise like there above,
so if I were to draw like a column,
you could think of this column as being,
having a tornado of fluid flow, right,
where it's, everything is
kind of rotating together
in that same direction.
So if you were to assign a
vector to each point in space
to describe the kind of rotation happening
around each one of those points in space,
you would expect that
those inside this column,
inside this sort of counter
clockwise rotating tornado,
and I say counter
clockwise, but if we viewed
it from below it would look clockwise,
so that's the tricky part
about three dimensions
and why we need to
describe it with vectors,
but you expect these using
your right hand rule,
where you curl the
fingers of your right hand
around the direction of rotation here,
you would expect vectors that
point up in the Z direction,
the positive Z direction,
and if I do that,
if I show what all of the
rotation vectors look like,
you'll get this, and maybe
this is kind of a mess
because there's a lot of things
on the screen at this point.
So for the moment I'll kind of
remove that original
vector field and remove
the XY plane, and just
kind of focus on this
new vector field that
I have pictured here.
Inside that column where we
have that tornado rotation
I was describing, all of the vectors
point in the positive Z direction,
but if we were to view it elsewhere,
like over in this region,
those are pointing in
the negative Z direction,
and if you stick your
thumb in the direction
of all of these vectors in
the negative Z direction,
that tells you the direction
of, that tells you how
the fluid, maybe you're
thinking of it as air
kind of rushing about the room,
how that fluid rotates
it in three dimensions.
So what curl is gonna
do, here I'll kind of
clear things up, I have
the formula from last time,
that hopefully hasn't looked too
in the way while I've been doing this,
that described curl for a
two dimensional vector field
if we imagine that's
not just taking X and Y
as its inputs because it's a
three dimensional vector field,
but if we imagine it taking X, Y and Z,
so it's a proper three
dimensional vector field,
the output is gonna tell
you at every point in space
what the rotation that
corresponds to that point is.
And in the next video I'm
gonna give you the formula
and tell you how you
actually compute this curl
given an arbitrary function,
but for right now we're just
getting the visual intuition,
we're just trying to understand
what it is that curl
is going to represent.
And in this vector field,
this one that was just kind of
copies of a 2D put above,
it's almost contrived
because all of the rotation
happens in these perfect
tornado-like patters that
doesn't really change
as you move up and down
in the XY direction,
but more generally you might
have a more complicated
looking vector field, so I'll go ahead and
finally erase this since it's
been a little bit in the way
for a while, and erase this guy too,
and if you think about just arbitrary
three dimensional vector
fields, like let's say
this one that I have here,
so I don't know about you,
but for me it's really hard
to think about the fluid flow
associated with this, I have
a vague notion in my mind
that okay, like fluid is
flowing out from this corner
and kind of flowing in here,
but it's very hard to
think about it all at once,
and certainly if you start
talking about rotation,
it's hard to look at
a given point and say,
oh yeah there's gonna be
a general fluid rotation
in some certain way and I can
give you the vector for that.
But as a more loose and
vague idea, I can say,
okay, given that there's
some kind of crazy
air current fluid flow
happening around here,
I can maybe understand
that at a specific point,
you're gonna have some kind of rotation,
and here I'll picture it
as if there's like a ball
or a globe sitting there
in space, and maybe you're
imagining your new vector field and saying
what kind of rotation is it kind of induce
in that ball that's just
floating there in space?
Maybe you're imagining this
as like a tennis ball that
you're sort of holding in
place in space using magnets
or magic or something like that,
and you're letting the wind
sort of freely rotate
it, and you're wondering
what direction it tends to rotate,
and then when it does and
when you have this rotation,
you can describe that 3D rotation
with some kind of vector,
and in this case it would
be a vector that points out
in that direction because we're
kind of curling our fingers,
curling our right hand fingers
over in that direction,
and if you don't understand
how we describe 3D rotation
with a vector, I have a
video on that, maybe go back
and check out that video,
but the idea here is that
when you have some sort
of crazy fluid flow
that's induced by some
sort of vector field,
and you do this at every point and say,
hey what's the rotation
at every single point,
that's gonna give you the
curl, that is what the curl
of a three dimensional vector
field is trying to represent.
And if this feels confusing,
if this feels like something
that's hard to wrap your
mind around, don't worry
we've been there, 3D curl is
one of the most complicated
things in multivariable calculus
that we have to describe.
But I think the key to
understanding it is to just kind of
patiently think through and
take the time to think about
what 2D curl is instead of
thinking about how you extend
that to three dimensions
and slowly say, okay, okay,
I kind of get it, tornados of rotation,
that sort of makes sense,
and if you understand
how to represent three
dimensional rotation around
a single point with a
vector, then understanding
three dimensional curl
comes down to thinking about
doing that at every single point in space
according to whatever rotation
the wind flow around
that point would induce.
Like I said, it is complicated,
and it's okay if it
doesn't sink the first
time, it certainly took me
awhile to really wrap my head
around this 3D curl idea,
and with that I'll see you next video.